have you heard from Kate saying that the
other four missed their siblings also I
don't hear from Kate so like it's just
totally like that person doesn't exist
anymore how are you doing with the
quarantine and you're clearly you know
working how's that we can go on
well quarantine zat home so I'm I'm fine
I'm in I'm the IT director of a health
care facility we see the undocumented
and uninsured right now we're doing
telemedicine when I telephonic and we're
using ringcentral through zoom to see
patients so we're not physically seeing
patients right now but my job was to set
up and teach providers which are doctors
on how to use telemedicine so I
developed a procedure rather quickly and
my boss the CIO bought software that we
never used before and I had to learn it
in five six hours and create a whole
procedure and teach doctors who have
been seeing patients for 30 years in
person and had to teach them how to see
patients online so it was very
interesting you always get my hair cut
when the boys get their hair cut that
way it's more convenient and I make the
appointment and then he's always there
it has now been ten years since you
divorced Kate what are those ten years
been like for you I've learned a lot
I've had a lot of lessons but I bounced
back I feel like I'm back to no I have
normalcy because I'm I'm still in the
same career that I was before the show
started so I was an IT before that I
don't know I just learned a lot of
lessons about people I've made great
relationships I've had bad relationships
but I've had a lot of lessons along the
way I feel like I'm strong advocate for
fathers and other single parents a lot
of people ask me for legal advice and
just parenting things you know why
reinvent the wheel
you know I've you know people call me a
DJ I'm glad I know how to DJ but that's
not a career
been an IT for a long time I created my
own wellness company of my friend a
friend of mine named Ben Quigley so
we're doing like a wellness thing that
helps boost your immune system so I've
gotten involved in a lot of different
aspects of businesses but I've met these
people along the way without my
celebrity or whatever you want to call
it I would have never met these people
yeah but it's interesting you mentioned
your celebrity because now you really
kind of try to shy away from her much
more and you you know at first you
didn't really want to talk did you you
what really want to kind of respect the
kids and keep them away from all this um
yeah I mean my kids now have kind of
just they want normalcy now so like even
doing this in our view this is kind of
like not the final final interviews but
this is me kind of saying like to the
world my kids want to be left alone and
they just want to have a normal teenage
life the kids my kids that live with me
because my other kids we're not really
communicating right now but the Hannah
and Collin that live with me
they're just said hey Dad can you just
go out there and say like hey we just
want to have a normal teenage you know
10th 11th and 12th grade year but uh
yeah it's different it's kind of like
you have to kind of live like two worlds
here I'm sitting in my normal job and my
lunch break doing an interview with et
so I have like my normal life and my
other life that's still kind of
following me it's kind of it's kind of
interesting
do you wish you could reunite the entire
family and all the kids I wish that my
kid all my kids would just be together
like hang out together go them all well
we can't do that now but you know what I
mean like just hang out together and it
wouldn't be I feel like it's East and
West Germany kind of you know because
Kate and I don't live that far away from
each other and I feel like there's an
invisible wall they should just be able
to just get together I mean I have no
qualms about it it you know if they're
they want to go meet each other just go
ahead but I think if I feel like it's
more on the other side who's stopping
them from coming together no I'm not
stopping them from coming together I
can't speak for the other side so I'm
hoping that
when my kids and they will get their
license and when I say my kids I am
referring to Hannah and Collin that
they'll just drive to school and pick up
their siblings and legally no one can
stop them from doing so
do they miss your siblings oh yeah
absolutely absolutely have you heard
from Kate saying that the other four
missed their siblings also I don't hear
from Kate so like it's just totally like
that person doesn't exist anymore is
that strange considering that you two
were like America's darlings for so long
and now you don't even exist each other
I think it's strange to you and the
outside world but to me it's a relief
I'm glad it's kind of over I mean we
have children together but we totally
see differently on how they should be
raised but they're older now so I mean
my name Cara gave me 20 in October and
the six just turned 16 so now it's like
okay well now we're moving into young
adults so we've moved past the
adolescent stage and now we just got to
move forward past that so on my side
with Hannah Khan we're doing family
therapy individual therapies and you
know moving past what they went through
dramatically from the show and from
other circumstances mmm you know that's
the way it is how is Colleen boy wow
she's super busy she has a lot of pain
she's a mental health nurse practitioner
she's incredibly busy I mean you think
of all the people with depression right
now and and all those kind of things
with you know losing their jobs and
losing money and no stimulus check is
gonna fix you know we're feeding their
families or you know I'm like I said in
March everything was really good and now
how are people gonna do this and that
those people are calling her and
scheduling appointments and I mean
there's a lot there's so much going on
it's super stressful how important is it
that you are with someone who is a
mental health professional and that she
is really in a way she can work with the
situation and the kids and all the
things more well there's two thoughts
that never art never argue with someone
who is this incredibly intelligent
you will lose you will definitely lose
it helps a lot on me I'm a lay person in
that aspect even though I work in the
healthcare field
nice I'm not a healthcare person so I
would be a non-clinical IT person so
there's a lot that I've learned and then
with Collins traumatologist and
therapists and all stuff I have to take
like parenting therapy to understand
where he's coming from how to rethink
and retrain my brain so there's a lot
that goes on so it's not just like you
don't just drop your kid off and then
come back and pick them up will you ever
or do you think there's a chance ever
that the kids as they get older they'll
say you know what let's go ahead and
feel well we're over 18 now let's how it
if my kids want to film or do anything
after 18 they're adults they can do
whatever they want they can write books
they can do I mean that's up to them I
can't stop them after they're 18 that's
it well you know the world will descend
on them you know when they do it at 18
there's gonna you dealt with this thing
where the vultures come out I mean are
they prepared for that or you have you
prepared them for that I try to prepare
the ones that live with me Hannah :
for that I mean I try to show them that
if you open this it changes things so
like my mom said likes about choices so
if you say some like action reaction you
say something expect you know there's
two sides to every story so even after
this interview people do why see talking
into them you should just keep his mouth
shut
I'm gonna read the comments after this
ding dinging and I'm just gonna be like
okay but if you don't have a voice you
know oh he should speak you should go
out there and defend this and that and
speak up for his so you're gonna have to
two levels all the time well you
mentioned that and does does that lead
to the Mother's Day thing that was
misinterpret ate those misinterpreted by
many people
so I'll just clear that up right now I
have a boy he didn't realize his account
was public
I don't know I just I like my kid that's
their phone well I can monitor MIT I can
monitor anything I'm just gonna you know
they know they know that I don't know in
them I know he didn't realize it was
public so he wrote a message to Colleen
and then Jordan like we were at this was
after the letter 16th birthday and mhm
we did a celebration all that stuff and
then Jordan showed it to me
and I was like uh almost again then I
googled and then it was already picked
up and I was like dude you got a you got
to make that private so then he's like
oh my god and then he made a private and
then you can see in the article you know
the the link the hyperlink so they don't
went private but he was kind of like
embarrassed cuz he wrote that to Colleen
and he he tagged her but he only had so
many followers so he was kind of like he
wasn't embarrassed he was embarrassed
that he thought it was private and then
went public and he didn't really want to
go the media but it did so but he's
alright but you have to remember these
are 16 year old kids fine
they don't care about this
do they ever go back and watch the show
the old field show
I don't now now because we don't even we
have like Roku sticks and stuff we don't
even they watch like YouTube and Netflix
and all that stuff
they want my Netflix password and that
that's that's it and Spotify or what do
you hope is the ending for these kids
like you know your kids how do you go
how do you hope these plays out for them
oh right now there it is playing out
there just they go to my kids go to
public school they just have their own
friends they get their license and kind
of I mean they're growing up in our
hometown like me and Colleen and we're
living in our hometown and everything's
kind of playing out you know there's
it's like you know it was normal
are you gonna be the reality shows the
car with the happy ending I already
think it is happy yeah no that's like it
just took me a while to figure out how
to either integrate the two like you you
have to either integrate it and just
deal with it and that's what I try to
tell like Hannah and Collin like you
can't change the past we just kind of
have to live with what had happened and
just move forward like you can't change
who you are what you're filmed already
you already filmed it and if they if the
network decides to rerun it oh well
you'll get a royalty check there you go
won't be much but yeah I still get a
royalty check who cares you know
whatever but it is what it is you know
you're part of it's part of the history
pretty much mm-hmm but you can't change
it so you got to just roll with it and
you can do good with it you know you
might have influenced someone or you you
could have impacted someone's life or
something different you know so you have
a platform you can use it it's smart way
to look at it
[Music]